Hey guys
It's turning into liquid nitrogen week on the king of Random and today is no [exception] for bizarre happenings
Welcome back to the king of random cooking show
I'm just joking this video [was] sponsored by a company called [hellofresh]
They send boxes of food to your door to make it easier and more convenient to make your meals
But my wife will tell you I am not much of a cook so rather than taking these ingredients and turning them into three
Gourmet meals like you're supposed to do [I] wonder what would happen if you took some fruits
Vegetables and even meat and dip them in a bath of liquid nitrogen just to see what would happen
Let's start off with a piece of lettuce
You know lettuce is Bendy, flimsy, and floppy, but if we stick that down into the [liquid] nitrogen that all changes very very quickly
And all it takes is a couple of seconds
You can see now. It's actually super crispy. Just flake in your hands and turn
That's cool. What happened if we put the whole thing in there?
All things getting pretty crispy now and watch this
Well, that's one way to shred your lettuce
next up
I think we be fun to try this chicken breast it's really squishy, really flimsy, and it's meat so let's see what liquid nitrogen
Does to meat start by cutting this thing open.
There's a healthy chicken breast
You know it's done when the bubbling starts to settle down now that right there is what you call flash-frozen
There we go. There's our piece of meat. You can see it's completely frozen if we take something like a sledgehammer
That's impressive
Figure this out if you move it around
[know] what sounds like
pieces of glass
Dropping down it looks and acts. Just like shards of glass it’s amazing. That's chicken
Let's try a little baby broccoli next you see this stuff is really limp and flimsy
Put that in for a few seconds
Here we go sautéed veggies extra crispy
You see when that broccoli is done. It is super Super crispy
That's amazing. What else we want to try tomato?
Look at it. Tomatoes change color as it freezes. It turns more of a whitey pasty color there we go
See it's already kind of cracked
Have pieces everywhere
Shatters
That used to be a tomato. You couldn't tell by looking at it. Could [you]?
Sounds like rocks or broken glass and it is a little bit cold. I think for my last experiment
I'm going to try ground beef because everybody knows what ground beef is like
It's not hard and [solid] it's very very squishy. This is kind of stuff you make your hamburger patties out of
There we go
Look at that
Turn it into a nice little hamburger ball
I think that might [be] a little bit too big let's turn them into smaller meatball [all] right
There we go
So I know this might seem a little bit wasteful
It was a lot of fun and don't worry every scrap that you see use here is going to be used for some purpose it
Will be taken care of so there will be no waste well guys that's it [for] this video
I hope you enjoyed some of these experiments
I had a lot of fun, and I hope you did as well big. Thanks to hello Fresh
I'm really impressed with the [quality] of food. I mean, this is stuff that we could eat and in all honesty this is stuff
We are going to eat now in a company like [hello] fresh reaches out to sponsor a video they also send these things called talking
points
Which are basically the things that they want me to tell you about their product and in this case
They want to know that hellofresh is the meal kit delivery service that makes cooking fun easy
And convenient and each week hellofresh creates new delicious recipes with Step-by-step
Instructions designed to take around 30 minutes for everyone from novices to seasoned home cooks short on time
They source the freshest ingredients measured to the exact quantities needed, so there's no food waste
They employ a full-time registered dietitian on staff who reviews each recipe to ensure
It's nutritionally balanced and it's all delivered to your doorstep in a special insulated box for free
so there you have it guys if you have any interest in the kind of service hellofresh has to offer go check them out and
Use the promo code at the king of Random, but if you're not interested, then don't worry about it
[I'm] just glad to have you along for the ride today of course
Liquid Nitrogen is for professionals and experts only this isn't something that I can recommend doing at home
But it is something that I sure enjoy doing with you today. Now. Who's going to clean up this mess, I?
Can't believe the guy is my wife salvaged all those scraps in the big mess that I made is turned it into this
How awesome is that that is what [we're] having for dinner tonight